. So we already looked at Donald Trump tweeting
endlessly during yesterday's public impeachment
hearings and we could focus in on almost any
element of the testimony and it would be pretty
interesting. But since the hearings mostly
confirmed and corroborated what was already
asserted, I want to focus a number one on
the new claims that were notable yesterday
because there were some, and I also want to
focus in on the reality that Donald Trump
and his followers lack both the attention
spans and the cognitive capacity to recognize
that there was new evidence yesterday and
to be able to parse the testimony. But William
Taylor presented new assertions directly implicating
Donald Trump in the bribery, which I think
is how we should refer to it.
We shouldn't refer to it as a quid pro quo.
That can be confusing. It sounds a a less
clear than than what we're talking about here,
which is bribery or extortion. William Taylor
said yesterday, and to me this was the biggest
new allegation from the hearings. William
Taylor said yesterday, former, uh, ambassador
to Ukraine, that on July 26, that's the day
after. Remember the phone call between Trump
and Zelenskyi? The Ukrainian president was
on July 25. William Taylor says that on July
26th, the EU ambassador Gordon Sunland called
Donald Trump from a restaurant. Sunland had
just met with Andre, your Mac. That's a name
we've mentioned before, and advisor to the
Ukrainian president. One of William Taylor
staff was at that restaurant and overheard
the phone call between Sunland and Trump and
says that Trump asked Sunland about the status
of quote the investigations, and of course
that is understood to mean the smear investigations
of Joe and Hunter Biden that Trump was demanding
Ukraine carry out and publicly announced.
Ambassador Sunland reportedly told president
Trump that the Ukrainians were ready to move
forward. According to William tell Taylor's
testimony yesterday after the call, Taylor
staffer asked Sunland, what does Trump think
about Ukraine? And Sunland responded, Trump
cares more about the investigations of Biden.
That was the priority for Donald Trump. It
was the only thing that Donald Trump actually
cared about. Let's look at a little bit of
that portion of the testimony.
The staff at a restaurant, Besser Soland called
president Trump and told him of his meetings
and cave, the member of my staff could hear
president Trump on the phone asking ambassador
Sanlon about the investigations. Mr Sandlin
told president Trump, the Ukrainians were
ready to move forward. Following the call
with president Trump, the member of my staff
asked ambassador Sullivan what president Trump
thought about Ukraine as a song and responded
that president Trump cares more about the
investigations of Biden, which Giuliani was
pressing for.
So this was new yesterday. This was not something
that Taylor mentioned during his previous
closed door testimony. Why wasn't it mentioned
before? Because Taylor learned about it after
his closed door testimony. Um, uh, and before
yesterday's testimony. Of course, now the
reason that I'm highlighting this is that
in hours and hours of testimony, much of it
is nuanced detail oriented, framed within
context and history because that's what's
necessary to understand this. I don't know
that all six hours were necessary. There were
about 30 minutes of grand standing arguing
about taking votes, about subpoenaing the
whistleblower and all this different stuff,
but there was much of that time was spent
on unimportant context and history. It can
be really easy to miss the forest for the
trees or for it all to blend together and
for us to come away with, wow. They talked
for a while, but I'm not really sure what
we actually learned from it.
This was a big deal because it is a new corroborating
claim to the broader narrative that's been
presented so far. But do you think Trump has
the patience or the capacity to realize this?
Of course not. And therefore Trump tweets
that it's a big nothing burger. His followers
repeat it. And on and on and on we go. This
is how Donald Trump has altered media and
our entire perception of important issues.
A witness gives damning testimony of what
is obvious and apparent wrongdoing by Donald
Trump, but Trump and his media sycophants
like those at Fox news complain that the testimony
wasn't explosive. It wasn't interesting effectively
saying it wasn't entertaining enough. It wasn't
enough like an action movie because it was
just people talking for six hours. And in
addition to the new evidence that we just
talked about, we also got confirmation of
many other things.
We got confirmation that officials that were
sort of surrounding this entire, uh, exchange
between Trump and Ukraine and the Trump administration
and Ukraine really, they saw Rudy Giuliani's
behavior as both and unprecedented. That's
important. People who tried to raise alarm
about what's going on, we're either ignored
or silence that was in yesterday's hearings,
but you wouldn't know that if you looked at
Trump's tweets or watched Fox news. Trump's
pressure on Ukraine was not merely a request.
It was real pressure. It was a, an attempted
extortion or bribery. So this is just the
beginning. We might feel like not much was
accomplished yesterday and I understand that,
but we had number one corroboration of just
about everything that we were told before
yesterday. And number two, the new evidence
about this phone call between Donald Trump
and Gordon Sunland. And then tomorrow we have
another hearing this time with Marie over
no bitch or Uganda bitch who was targeted
by a Trump Rudy smear campaign and I believe
may actually be far more explosive and interesting
testimony than what we got yesterday.
There's a reason that the only thing Republicans
could do yesterday is say aren't memories
sometimes wrong and they just droned on and
on for hours, not really saying anything.
The reason why is because the substance of
yesterday's testimony was devastating to Donald
Trump. If you knew what to listen for, if
you actually were paying attention and thinking
through what it is that was being said yesterday,
so we will cover it. We will be live tomorrow
with a Marie Avanti vicious testimony. I encourage
you to watch that at youtube.com/the David
Pakman show reminder on Thanksgiving, we will
be having our, uh, what I believe is going
to be our last membership drive of the year.
If you've been thinking about getting a membership
to the show and you really should, um, it
is going to be the biggest discount of the
year. We will notify everybody on our mailing
list to get on the mailing list, go to David
pakman.com you'll see how to sign up. I don't
remember if it says mailing list or newsletter.
In any case, sign up for that. And then on
Thanksgiving you will be notified about this
extraordinarily explosive offer, uh, that
will be, um, available for one day. Follow
me on Twitter at D Pacman. Let me know what
you think about yesterday's impeachment inquiry
hearings. Agree with me. Yes.
Disagree with me. A little bit of both. They
want to hear the